California es uno de los estados con los impuestos
más altos de todo Estados Unidos. Y también
uno de los más caros ¡No sólo eso! El Gobierno
de California vive en un contínuo riesgo
de bancarrota, con unas deudas y unos déficits
fiscales brutales.
Sin embargo y pese a todo
esto, en California es donde está la tercera
zona más rica y próspera del planeta Tierra.
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik, estoy hablando
del valle de Santa Clara
¿Qué decís? ¿Qué
no sabéis de lo que hablo? Tal vez os suene
más el nombre popular que recibe esta zona:
SILICON VALLEY.
¡Exacto! el lugar donde nacieron empresas
como Google, Apple y, por supuesto YouTube.
Y lo más llamativo de todo es que no se trata
de ninguna gran metrópolis como pueda ser
Nueva York o Londres ¡Todo lo contrario!
Ciudades como Cupertino, Palo Alto o Mountain
View tienen poco más de 60.000 habitantes.
Menlo Park, que es donde Facebook tiene la
sede, es más pequeño que, incluso Teruel,
la capital más pequeña de España. Pues
bien, en esta zona, el salario medio supera
los 10.000 dólares al mes y es donde viven
muchas de las mayores fortunas del planeta.
Y por si alguno se lo preguntaba: no. No hay
ninguna mina de Silicio en el valle de Santa Clara.
El nombre de Silicon Valley se empezó
a usar en los años 70 porque aquí es donde
se fabricaban los microchips y semiconductores,
que están hechos de silicio. Pero no lo busquéis
porque no hay recursos naturales por ningún
lado.
Y la pregunta es ¿Por qué aquí? Es decir
¿Qué tiene de especial Silicon Valley para
tener tantísimas empresas? Por ejemplo: es
fácil entender por qué Suiza es tan rica:
tienen impuestos bajos y un sistema político
único en el mundo. Lo mismo ocurre con muchos
otros países de los que os hemos hablado
aquí, en VisualPolitik. Sin embargo, desde
el punto de vista de la política… Silicon
Valley no tiene nada especial. Es más, como
os hemos dicho, California es uno de los estados
con mayor carga fiscal de todo Estados Unidos.
Por ejemplo: imagina que eres un directivo
de una empresa y que cobras medio millón
de dólares al año. Si vivieras en Texas,
pagarías un 32% de impuesto sobre la renta.
Sin embargo, en California tendrías que pagar
un 42%. En otras palabras, que no hablamos
de una diferencia pequeña.
Así que la pregunta es… ¿Por qué Silicon
Valley y no Texas, o Delaware, o cualquier
otro lugar? Y lo que es más importante ¿Qué
hace tan especial a Silicon Valley? ¿Cómo
se crea una startup? Hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes, vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
LOS OCHO TRAIDORES
Hay momentos en la historia donde se dan todas
las casualidades para generar un milagro.
Así nació Silicon Valley.
Nuestra historia empieza en el año 1956 con
una empresa que se llamaba LABORATORIO DE
SEMICONDUCTORES SHOCKLEY.
Estos fueron los primeros en fabricar microchips basados en Silicio. Sus oficinas estaban en un pueblecito
de poco más de 7000 habitantes que se llamaba
MOUNTAIN VIEW. Un pueblecito a las afueras
de San Francisco.
Por aquel entonces, nadie hablaba de Silicon
Valley. Por supuesto, la península de San
Francisco ya era una de las capitales tecnológicas
de Estados Unidos. De hecho, los radares que
usaba el ejército estadounidense ya estaban
fabricados por una empresa que seguro que
os va a sonar a todos: Hewlett Packard.
Y la Universidad de Standford ya generaba profesionales
formados en las tecnologías más punteras.
Pero volvamos a nuestros amigos de Shockley.
Sus circuitos integrados eran lo más innovadores
del momento. Y, probablemente, esta empresa
podría haber llegado muy lejos. Pero tenían
un problema.
Por lo visto, el jefe era un
señor insoportable. Tal cual como lo oís
¿Y qué creéis que pasó? Pues que un buen
día, 8 de sus trabajadores más jóvenes
se plantaron en la oficina del jefe, el Señor
William Shockley y le dijeron: “te puedes
meter tu empresa por el culo. Nosotros somos
los que hemos desarrollado TU tecnología.
Somos el cerebro de este negocio. Así que
vamos a montar nuestro propio negocio y te
vas a enterar”. A estos 8 señores se les
conoce como los “8 traidores.
¡Pero esperad
un momento! Porque creo que no os habéis
dado cuenta de lo arriesgada que era esta
operación. Estos 8 traidores tenían una
media de 30 años cada uno. No tenían dinero
y querían montar una empresa hipertecnológica
que requería un montón de inversión ¿Creéis
que algún banco les daría un préstamo?
Obviamente no. Mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
en el año 1959, nació la primera empresa
financiada íntegramente con un fondo de Capital
Riesgo ¿Y esto qué significa? Ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver.
EL VALOR DE UNA IDEA
Desde los inicios del capitalismo, siempre
ha habido gente con dinero dispuestos a asociarse
con gente con ideas para montar empresas.
Sin embargo, después de la segunda guerra
mundial, montones de soldados vuelven del
frente.
Y 1 de cada 2 veteranos quiere montar
empresas. Es decir, que de repente hay muchísima
demanda para financiar negocios.
Y eso lleva a que mucha de esta gente con
dinero se replantee las cosas. Por ejemplo…
Lawrence Rockefeller, de los Rockefeller de
toda la vida.
Este hombre no sólo tenía
dinero. También conocía a otras personas
que también tenían mucho dinero. Así que,
en el año 1959 les llamó a todos y les dijo
“a ver, mis queridos amigos millonarios,
dejad vuestras copas de champán por un momento
y prestad atención. He encontrado a 8 chicos
en California que tienen una idea fantástica,
son más listos que el hambre y quieren desarrollar
nosequé de un circuito integrado con silicio.
Así que, si queréis, me dais vuestro dinero,
yo lo invierto en su negocio y si sale bien,
nos forramos”.
Y, como decimos siempre en VisualPolitik,
dicho y hecho.
Así es como en 1959, los 8
traidores de Silicon Valley, con el dinero
de Rockefeller, montaron FAIRCHILD, la primera
empresa en comercializar microchips de silicio.
¡Pero no sólo eso! Así es como nació uno
de los primeros fondos de capital riesgo VENROCK
ASSOCIATED ¿Y dónde tienen la sede? En Palo
Alto ¡Eso está en Silicon Valley!!!
Por supuesto, la idea era muy arriesgada.
Por eso se llaman fondos de capital riesgo.
Es decir, si tu inviertes tu dinero en una
empresa que ya existe como, por ejemplo, Coca
Cola, es difícil que te arruines. Sin embargo,
dar dinero a alguien que sólo tiene una idea
y mucho talento es una auténtica locura ¿Cuál
es la ventaja? Que, si te sale bien, multiplicas
tu valor ¿Dónde está el secreto? En invertir
en muchas ideas a la vez. Basta con que 1
de cada 10 te salga bien para que hayas amortizado
la inversión.
Y lo cierto es que a nuestro amigo, el señor
Rockefeller, la inversión en FAIRCHILD le
salió a las mil maravillas. Tanto es así
que la empresa todavía existe y tiene oficinas
por todo el mundo.
¿Y qué pasa cuando te van las cosas bien?
Pues que otros salen a imitarte. Para el año
1982 ya había 12 Fondos de Capital Riesgo
establecidos en alguno de los municipios de
Silicon Valley. La filosofía es muy sencilla:
el fondo atrae dinero de inversores privados,
planes de pensiones y, por supuesto, millonarios
de todo Estados Unidos y de todo el Mundo.
Y, después, los profesionales que trabajan
para el fondo se reúnen con los emprendedores
y van buscando qué ideas merecen la pena
y qué ideas no merecen la pena.
En resumen: que Silicon Valley lo tenía,
y lo tiene todo: profesionales de altísimo
nivel que se forman en la Universidad de Standford,
profesionales de altísimo nivel que se forman
en todo el mundo y que terminan, tarde o temprano,
emigrando a Silicon Valley, un tejido empresarial
que facilita crear nuevos negocios y, sobretodo,
el dinero de todo el mundo. El resto es historia.
Pero vale, todo esto suena muy bien pero…
¿Cómo es una empresa de Silicon Valley?
¿Cómo funciona este sistema de startups
y fondos de capital riesgo? Pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver.
EL MÉTODO SILICON VALLEY
Lo sé, lo sé… hoy en día, el término
STARTUP se ha convertido en una de esas palabras
que dicen los idiotas cuando quieren parecer
inteligentes. Así ¿Cuál es la diferencia
entre una empresa y una startup? Pues aquí
tenéis una buena definición.
“Una startup es una empresa diseñada para
crecer rápido” –Paul Graham, creador
de Yahoo! Store e inversor de riesgo
¡Ya sé lo que estáis pensando! ¿No se
supone que todas las empresas están diseñadas
para crecer rápido? La respuesta es no. Por
ejemplo: IKEA.
IKEA puede ser una de las compañías más
exitosas de todos los tiempos. Pero una de
sus máximas desde los inicios era que sólo
podían crecer usando sus propios fondos.
Ni deudas con bancos ni fondos de inversión.
Eso significa que, a diferencia de otras empresas,
Ikea tardó mucho más en crecer, aunque lo
hizo de una forma más estable.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Quién sí sería una
startup, entonces? Pues Facebook, por ejemplo.
¿Por qué? Primero porque Facebook es un
negocio escalable. Es decir, da igual si tiene
1 o 1 millón de usuarios: los gastos son
prácticamente los mismos ¡Pero no sólo
eso! Facebook es un ejemplo de libro de lo
que se conoce como el Ciclo de financiación
de una startup.
Y prestad atención porque
esto es la clave del funcionamiento de Silicon
Valley.
El primer paso es lo que se conoce como el
VALLE DE LA MUERTE ¿Porqué lo llaman así?
Porque es el momento donde la mayor parte
de de los proyectos no llegan a sobrevivir.
En este caso, teníamos a nuestros amigos
Marc Zuckerberg y Eduardo Saverin que tenían
una muy buena idea bajo el brazo. Pero, tener
una muy buena idea, por sí mismo, no sirve
de nada. Hay que ejecutarlo. Así que estos
dos amigos pusieron dinero de su propio bolsillo
para sacar el primer prototipo de la página.
En este caso, THEFACEBOOK.COM.
El resto de
la historia ya la conocéis. En seguida, todos
los alumnos de Harvard tenían una cuenta,
el proyecto prometía… Bien. Siguiente paso.
Tienen que convertirse en una empresa como
Dios manda. Y para eso hace falta dinero.
Dinero con el que pagar servidores, programadores,
etc… ¿Tenían ese dinero? Obviamente no
¿Qué hicieron entonces? Marcharse a Silicon
Valley y reunirse con este señor que veis
en la pantalla, que se llama PETER THIEL.
Y atentos porque aquí llega la primera gran
diferencia entre emprender en Silicon Valley
o emprender en cualquier otro lugar. Peter
Thiel es lo que se conoce como un Business
Angel. Es decir, un señor con mucho dinero
que está dispuesto a invertir en una empresa
que todavía se encuentra en ese valle de
la muerte. En ese momento, el año 2004, Facebook
era una idea con mucho potencial pero que
ni siquiera daba beneficios. La inversión
es tan arriesgada que ningún banco les prestaría
dinero ¿Cuál es la ventaja, entonces? Pues
que cuando Peter Thiel metió medio millón
de dólares en Facebook, estaba comprando
un 10% de la empresa. Y diréis ¿Por qué
sólo un 10%? A fin de cuentas, en ese momento,
Facebook no valía nada. Con ese medio millón
de dólares, Peter Thiel podía exigir el
50 o incluso el 100% de la empresa ¿Verdad?
Pues sí, podría hacerlo si estuviera en
un lugar remoto de Alabama. Pero esto es Silicon
Valley y hay cientos de Business angels como
Peter Thiel. Así que todos ellos compiten
por ofrecer buenas condiciones a sus emprendedores
¿Empezáis a entender por qué merece la
pena emprender en esta zona?
Pues bien, volvamos a la historia.
Con ese medio millón de dólares, los fundadores
ya pueden crear algo grande. Algo comercializable.
Dicho de otra forma, este es el momento donde
se ve si una empresa sobrevive, o no, al valle
de la muerte.
¡Pero la cosa no se queda aquí! Probablemente,
si Facebook se hubiera fundado en Alabama,
se habrían quedado en esta fase. Ya tienen
un producto, funciona, basta con que de beneficios
suficientes como para cubrir gastos. Punto
¿Pero recordáis que esto es una startup?
¿Y que su propósito es crecer lo más rápido
posible?
¡Pues aquí es donde entran los fondos de
capital riesgo!
Ya no hablamos de un señor
como Peter Thiel, que tiene mucho dinero y
lo invierte. Se trata de empresas especializadas.
Empresas que no sólo dan dinero sino que
también asesoran. Y esto es muy importante
porque en muchos casos pueden llegar a tomar
decisiones cruciales de tu empresa y a decirte
cómo tienes que diseñar tu estructura corporativa,
con qué otras empresas te tienes que asociar
o incluso cuándo tienes que salir al mercado
internacional.
En este caso, en el año 2005, un fondo que
se llama ACCEL PARTNERS, metió la friolera
de 12.7 millones de dólares. Con esto se
quedaban con el 13 por ciento de la empresa.
Y aquí vamos a hacer un paréntesis. Si recordáis,
Peter Thiel había comprado un 10 por ciento
de Facebook por medio millón de dólares.
Sin embargo, ahora ACCEL Partners ha pagado
12,7 millones por el 13%. Eso significa que,
de la noche a la mañana, Facebook se ha revalorizado
y ahora vale 98 millones de dólares. Dicho
de otra forma: en menos de un año, la inversión
de Peter Thiel ya se ha multiplicado por casi
un 2000%
¿Cómo os quedáis? Pues esperad que no habéis
visto nada.
Esta entrada de capital de ACCEL Partners
es lo que se conoce como una ronda de inversión
de SERIE A. Y si existe una SERIE A, es porque
luego hay una SERIE B o incluso una C. En
este caso, la ronda de serie C la protagonizó
Microsoft en el año 2007. Y atentos a los
números porque os va a explotar la p**a cabeza.
Microsoft pagó 240 millones de dólares por
un 1,6% de Facebook. Si hacemos la regla de
tres, tenemos que, en ese momento, Facebook
ya vale 15.000.000 millones de dólares. Eso
significa, que ese 10% que compró Peter Thiel
por medio millón de dólares, se ha revalorizado
ahora en un 300.000%. En sólo 3 años.
Dicho de otra forma: si tu hubieras metido
100 dólares en Facebook en el año 2004,
ahora mismo te podrías comprar una casa con
piscina, trastero y hasta campo de minigolf.
Pero vale, ya sé lo que os estáis preguntando
¿De verdad Facebook vale todo eso? Es decir…
¿En el año 2007, Facebook daba tantos beneficios
como para justificar la inversión? Pues…
no. Pero veréis, con todo ese dinero se pueden
hacer muchas cosas. Cosas que tarde o temprano
terminarán dando beneficios.
Y aquí es cuando llegamos a la fase final
de la startup. El momento en el que tienen
que tomar la decisión crucial: ¿Vendemos
o salimos a bolsa? En el caso de Facebook,
decidieron salir a bolsa. Pero muchas otras
empresas terminan siendo compradas por grandes
multinacionales.
Apple compra SHAZAM por 400 millones de dólares
Y ya sé lo que me vais a decir “Fonseca,
todo esto suena muy bonito… pero no me creo
que sea tan fácil”. Y lo cierto es que
9 de cada 10 startups fracasan por el camino.
Pero basta con que 1 funcione para que un
montón de gente se haga millonaria.
Y eso explica que la máxima de la política
hoy en día sea “ponga un Silicon Valley
en su vida”
Por qué las calles de Berlín son el nuevo
Silicon Valley de Europa
Guadalajara, el Silicon Valley Mexicano
Los nuevos Silicon Valleys de África
En fin, que todo el mundo quiere tener un
Silicon Valley en las puertas de su casa.
Bueno, todo el mundo, menos la gente que vive
en Silicon Valley.
La élite tecnológica está abandonando Silicon
Valley en manada
Pero de esto vamos a hablar en otro vídeo.
Mientras tanto, la pregunta es: ¿Creéis
que se puede replicar el modelo de Silicon
Valley en otros países? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis visitar nuestra
página de PATREON para apoyar este proyecto.
Recordad que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos a este canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.